completely at random they just go up to
people and say you're not meant to be
at an unauthorized protest this is
forbidden because of the pandemic
and then they seem to just pick
protesters off
it's very similar actually to how it was
in summer 2019 uh but this
went when when protesters came out in
moscow
to protest about parliamentary elections
but this time around
it is protests across this whole country
in more than 90 cities
the navalny teams headquarters said that
uh demonstrations had been registered in
the far east
all the way across siberia in
temperatures of minus 50 degrees
in yakutsk people were coming out and
around
240 detentions so far we've heard and
i've already seen
about 15 people detained here in moscow
and the rally was only meant to start
just
10 minutes ago there don't seem to be
huge numbers of people out here in the
same way as there have been in
cities in the far east but i imagine
that more and more will come
but the last few days the authorities
have really been trying
to intimidate people to make sure they
understand that there will be a harsh
crackdown
they've also been very aware of the kind
of popularity that navalny's message has
gained especially
on the social media website tiktok there
have been 300 million views
of pro navalny content on tick-tock and
alexei navalny himself
from prison um praised the school
children who had wreaked havoc
on tick-tock and that has resulted in
messages
on state media encouraging parents to
make sure they kept their children at
home
we've had messages from the ministry of
education saying that
uh there are other activities that you
can do with your children at the weekend
but i just spoke to a 16 year old who'd
come out here he said that his school
had told him
that he should stay for extra lessons at
school
that his parents had hoped he wouldn't
come but that he wanted to come out not
just for alexei navalny but for himself
for his right to defend
his opinions and for the future of
russia very brave
people out but it isn't just children it
is people of every
age come out here and if you look at the
pictures from
all of these cities across russia people
of
every age come out to defend their
rights to fight for their freedom
uh and to try and secure the freedom of
alexei navalny although i really don't
think after
this huge investigation uh into putin's
alleged palace on the black sea resort
that the kremlin is going to look very
kindly on
uh thinking about freeing him